we're on problem 30.
see they've drawn a circle there if o is
the center of the circle above what
fraction of the circle is shaded
let me draw that
they draw a circle
and then they have two lines that go
through the center essentially
and one line looks like
that
another line
looks something like
that
and then they tell us well they tell us
that this is the center
o
they tell us this is 150 degrees
so the question is what fraction of the
circular region is shaded and the shaded
region is this
this is the shaded region
so we just have to figure out what
percentage of the total degrees in the
circle are shaded so let's think about
it this way if this is 150 degrees
what is this angle right here
well this angle in 150 degrees are
supplementary right so this so this
angle plus this angle is going to be
equal 180. so 30 plus 150 is equal to
and you could either say oh these are
opposite angles so they're equal or you
can make the same argument here that 150
plus this angle has to be equal to 180
so this angle is also equal to 30.
so what is the total angle measure of
the short shaded region you have 30
degrees here and you have 30 degrees
here so a total of 60 degrees
and the whole circle is how many degrees
if you went all the way around the
circle how many degrees is that well
that's 360 degrees
so 6 over 360 over 360 that's 1 6 of the
circle is shaded
and that is choice c
question 31
this was question 30.
question 31 if juan takes 11 seconds to
run
y yards
so
why
yards
for every 11 seconds
or another way you could think about it
is y over 11 yards per second fair
enough how many seconds will it take him
to run x yards at the same rate
x yards at the same rate
so he is going
at y yards per second so how many how
long will it take him to go x yards well
if i said that
i'm going at five miles per hour how
long will i take me to go 10 miles
let's say i go 5 miles per hour 5 miles
per hour let's say 5 meters per hour how
long will it take me to go 10 meters
you would say 10
divided by 5 is equal to 2 2 hours
so likewise we have his
his
speed right that's the speed we're
talking about how fast he runs his speed
is y over 11
y over 11 yards
per second
right
and we want to know how long will it
take him to run x yards
so we could just take x
divided by the speed
divided by y over 11 and we'll get
we'll get the answer in seconds
and you could work out the units but x
divided by y over 11 let's say things x
times 11 over y
equals 11
x over y another way to view it is this
is this is equal to the rate right
and we know from
probably the first day in physics the
distance is equal to rate times time
this might be an easier way for you to
think about it i want to just
however it best forms connections in
your brain distance is equal to rate
times time they tell us that the
distance is x
and that the rate is y over 11 yards per
second
y over 11
yards per second
so you y over 11 times t is equal to x
so if you want to find t you do x
divided by y over 11.
anyway you get 11x over y
which is choice a
question 32
question
32. john has 10 pairs of matched socks
10 matched
if he loses 7 individual socks
what is the greatest number of pairs of
matched socks
he can have left so he loses seven
he loses seven socks
so think about it if you wanted to
optimize the number of matched pairs
kind of what's the worst case scenario
the worst case scenario is if every one
of these
if every one of these socks came out of
a different pair right because then he'd
be left with seven socks that had that
you know their their brother socks or
whatever you want to call it their twin
socks are gone so that's the worst case
but we want to think about the best case
what's the best case if you want to
preserve the number of pairs you have
left
if you want to preserve the number of
pairs you left the 7 should have as many
pairs as possible
left in it right so if 7 could be made
of three pairs
and one lone socks
right this is kind of the best case
scenario if he wants to have the
greatest number of matched socks left so
the seven could be three pairs and one
lone sox in which case he'd be left with
what he would be left so these three
pairs would be gone remember he has ten
pairs
let's keep in mind those aren't ten
socks he has ten pairs so if he loses
let's say he just loses three pairs then
he'll just have seven pairs left right
but then if he loses one more sock
then he's only gonna have six pairs left
he's gonna have six pairs and one sock
so he's gonna have six matched pairs
left and that's choice b
question 33
the worst case if the question was the
other way i'm maybe i'm just overly
fascinated this question but if the
question was the other way what's the
worst case if if what's the what's the
the minimum number of pairs that he has
left you could say well all of these
each of these socks exactly destroy one
pair so losing seven socks destroy seven
pairs so at the worst case if each of
these were different socks from a
different pair he would have three pairs
left but anyway that's not what they
asked so i shouldn't focus on it
23 what is the lowest positive integer
that is divisible by each of the numbers
1 through seven inclusive
one through seven including one and
seven so let's think of a number that's
that's divisible by all of these so it
has to be divisible by seven right
seven's a prime number and it's the
largest of all so it has to be divisible
by seven
it has to be divisible by six
and seven and six share no common
factors so the number is going to be at
least seven times six
it has to be divisible by five
because five is a prime number
and it doesn't share and because of that
doesn't share any factors with any of
these numbers it has to be divisible by
four right
but four
think about it six is two times three
right
so to make it divisible by four you only
have to multiply it by another two so it
has two times two in its prime
factorization maybe that's how i should
be writing it it has to be divisible by
seven has to be divided by six which is
the same way of saying it has to be
divisible by two times three
has to be divisible by 5.
it has to be divisible by 4
but we already have one of two's one of
four's fractures here it's two so we
just multiply it by another two
right so this is to say it's divisible
by four
has to be divisible by 3 well it's
already divisible by 3
it has to be divisible by 2 it's already
divisible by 2 actually twice it has to
be divisible by 1 and that's already the
case so this is the number
and notice i was very careful not to
have extra prime factors if i just did 7
times 6 times 5 times 4 times 3 times 2
times 1 i would have gotten a number
that is divisible by all of them but it
wouldn't have been the smallest one
so anyway what is this number let's do
the small numbers first seven times well
i'll do the big number for 7 times 5 is
2 times 3
is 6 times 2 is 12 so 35 times 12
35 times 12
35 times 2 is 70
0 1 times 35 is 350
and then i have
7 plus 5 is 12
420 that is choice
a and you can feel good about it because
it's also the lowest number on their
list
next question
what percentage of 30
is 12
so 12 is equal to some decimal times 30
and we can convert that decimal
eventually to to a percent just multiply
by 100. so
x is equal to 30 sorry z divide both
sides by is equal to 12 over 30
which is the same thing as
what
4 over 10 right divided 4 over 10
right which equals 0.4
and if you wanted to write a decimal as
a percent you just multiply by 100 that
is equal to 40 percent
and that is choice d
and you know these can be confusing so
it's very important to write it that way
you know what percentage of 30 is 12. so
12 is what percentage of 30. it's going
to be a smaller number you can kind of
think 12 is what fraction of 30 or you
could say 12 30 equals what as a
percentage
equals x percent you could think of it
that way too it's all the same thing the
important thing is to get the to be able
to parse the language correctly anyway
thirty five
if
one point five
over
point two plus x
is equal to five then x is equal to
let's just solve it multiply both sides
of this equation by point two plus x
point two plus x
on the left hand side it cancels out we
just have 1.5 on the right-hand side
what's 5 times 0.2
it's 1 right 1.2 the same thing as 20 or
one-fifth so it's 5 times one-fifth
that's 1. you could think of it a bunch
of ways plus 5x
subtract 1 from both sides you have 0.5
right 1.5 minus 1 is 0.5 is equal to 5x
so x is equal to 0.5 divided by 5. well
that's just equal to 0.1
the answer is
b
see in the next video